She wrote it, she sent it, I'm*d
- Having an unsend is bad.
But being on the receiving end
of an unsend is even worse.
I went on a date with
this lovely lady.
Let's call her Pam.
It wasn't terribly great.
I was just kind of
hoping that maybe
I just wouldn't hear from her.
Two days go by, I get a
text message from Pam.
"Hey, I had a great time.
"What are you doing tonight?"
It was a Saturday by
the way and even if I
had a great time
I don't know if I
was ready to give
up my Saturday.
At this point I don't
really know what to do.
I don't want to be a dick.
And then Pam sends a text
message and it's really long.
Nothing this long is ever
good in a text message.
I mean I feel like we
can all agree on that.
- [Group] Yes!
I quickly realized it's
not addressed to me.
It's addressed to
a friend of Pam's.
"So I've asked him what
he's doing tonight.
"He's busy.
"Oh by the way,
he just liked another girl's
picture on Instagram."
Which I thought was
a bit of a red flag.
Now I don't know what to do.
But before I even get
a chance to decide
I get another text from Pam.
"OMG I can't believe
I sent that to you.
"I'm guessing you don't want
to go out with me anymore."
I didn't.
So I panic and feel
really bad and reply,
"Oh, no big deal.
"I'll totally go
with you again."
Pro tip.
Sometimes ghosting is the
nicest thing you can do.